un modelo francés de fin de la vida es
lo que pretende construir de forma
colectiva el presidente macrón el
mandatario pidió que el texto garantice
la expresión de la voluntad libre Clara
y reiterada de la elección de poner fin
a la vida propia y la incurabilidad del
sufrimiento psíquico y físico o el
compromiso del pronóstico vital la
propuesta tiene como base el informe
final de una convención de cerca de 200
ciudadanos franceses conformada en un
sorteo esa comisión entregó propuestas
para legalizar la eutanasia o el
suicidio asistido la legislación actual
permite a los cuidadores sedar de forma
Irreversible únicamente a pacientes
próximos a la muerte cuyo sufrimiento es
intolerable pero esa ley es tan limitada
que en la práctica cientos de personas
sobre todo con enfermedades
neurodegenerativas buscan acceso a la
muerte activa en naciones vecinas y solo
logran hacerlos hacerlo quienes tienen
recursos el presidente de francés Indicó
que no aceptará todas las propuestas de
ese informe ciudadano dijo esta mañana
que la asistencia activa al morir nunca
debe realizarse por una razón social por
ejemplo si el motivo es el aislamiento
de un enfermo que se sabe condenado a
muerte o sus sentimientos de culpa por
ser una carga y tampoco podrán acceder a
esos servicios pacientes menores de 18
años adicionalmente el jefe de estado
anunció inversiones y un plan Nacional
de diez años para el manejo del dolor y
cuidados paliativos actualmente el país
cuenta con apenas tres camas con ese
tipo de atención por cada 100.000
habitantes